you know in a few years these boys will  be very important you got quite a posh  name miles are you the riot club the  riot club hundreds of years at the best  and the brightest over here we have a  portrait of so the cockatoo that  I'm so sorry  not just offering your tough  I'm offering your future it's our time  gentlemen  I really shouldn't be doing this  for the top university in the world and  220 thousand other people  but there are no more than 10 in the  riot club  are you sure you want to be in this  thing these people are not your friends  they don't know when to stop  it's time for you to leave  books need your hope ambulance please  some examined could have just been a  mistake people like our sin 8 mistakes  I am sick to death of poor people  I didn't do this  dude it's the club right we all do this  you